heading into the Baltic Sea we're on our
way to a crime scene
the site of suspected sabotage
an alleged attack on nordstream
biggest underwater gas pipeline from
Russia to Europe
what does that mean skull and crossbones
that is the leak that's the leak that is
the league
this is an exclusion zone of around 9km
kilometers wide and that's as close as
we're allowed to get it's only the
military and investigators to allowed
any closer to those gas leaks as they
try to protect the evidence and find out
what happens here and who's responsible
it doesn't take long before we're warned
off
[Music]
the discovery of four leaks off the
coasts of Sweden and Denmark has sparked
an international crisis
deeply worrying for those like Kim who
could smell the gas from his home on the
Danish island of born home do you feel
vulnerable living on blonde home that it
happened so close yeah because where we
say well harm has always been a really
peaceful place and now we see warship if
16 everything and now it explosion so
close to Denmark
in the U.S and Europe many believe the
damage was deliberate potentially
ordered by Russia President Putin's
accused Anglo-Saxon powers of blowing up
the pipeline
who do you think is responsible
I don't know but I will not say I know
who will have done it but I definitely
know the Russian guy will try it maybe
to hold Europe in a tighter hand because
they know it's going to be winter now
bornheim's proximity to the leaks means
chemical experts are monitoring the air
to check it hasn't been poisoned so far
nothing's been detected here but the
un's warned the ruptures May Mark the
single biggest release of climate
damaging methane turn from a climate
environmental campaigners say this isn't
just a political crisis it's an
environmental disaster what kind of
impact could this have then well this
will contribute to the climate crisis
that we're in the middle of methane
being such a potent and aggressive
climate gas this is something that
really will be felt over a 20-year
period this is comparable to the whole
Danish emissions of CO2 right or what
maybe 30 million cars in Europe would
emit in one year
the full implications of what happened
off this Coast are still playing out a
tense moment not just for this community
but the whole world Siobhan Robbins Sky
News born home Denmark